good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric gershon our guest today is
dr. Thomas Lynch director of the Yale
Cancer Center and physician-in-chief at
smile cancer hospital at yale-new Haven
today we'll talk with him about some of
the latest developments in cancer
research and care and of course as
always we'll ask him some of your
questions glad to have you with us Eric
great to be here let's start with a big
picture question what is it about cancer
as a general category of disease that
makes it so powerful and so hard to cure
what makes cancer different is it cancer
is a disease of genes the same genes
that make our normal cells work well
those same genes get become abnormal get
taken over and become cancerous and the
cells grow uncontrollably and what makes
it such a difficult disease to control
is that to interrupt those genes it's
the same gene processes that we need in
regular cells whereas when you have an
infection with a bacteria or a virus
it's a different set of proteins you can
go after so you have different targets
that aren't innately human and they're
not innately part of us the way it
cancer cells really very similar to a
liver cell or a lung cell and our basic
our basic is basic cancer research
basically keeping up with treatment or
that are they tracking each other as we
learn a lot more about how cancer works
are we also coming up with newer
treatments almost as as fast well i
would say we're probably a little behind
on the newer treatments we've we've
jumped ahead dramatically in the
understanding of cancer over the past
five years so we've known for quite some
time the cancers disease caused by
abnormal genes the genes the gene
genetic changes drive cancer that was
known probably 25 years ago however
what's been learned over the past five
years is what the extent and nature of
those genetic changes are like and
that's because the ability to sequence
DNA and look at genetic changes has
advanced dramatically rapidly for
example at Yale's west campus we have
one of the world's largest genomic
facilities under the direction of rick
lifton where we can sequence an entire
human genome in about six days five to
six days and get that information that
uses
take 2-3 years in fact the first human
genome took 12 years to be done so you
can see that this ability to look within
each cancer cells genes and rapidly
detect what's normal and what's abnormal
has led to this incredible understanding
of what drives cancer however what we
don't know is how to change that and
that's why therapy is a little bit
behind our understanding and I think
that's going to exist for the next
several years lately we we hear a lot
about personalized medicine can you talk
to us a little bit about what that means
and especially in its relation to
treating cancer sorry that's a great
example so what we've talked about
personalized medicine is we can look at
mrs. Johnson's lung cancer and we can
look inside her lung cancer cells and
find out which cells what genes are
abnormal and direct a specific therapy
to her genes or we can look at mr.
Ramirez's lung cancer and figure out it
might be a different set of genes
they're abnormal in his situation and so
we would give different drugs in that
setting when I started off as an
oncologist 20 years ago we would give
the same drugs to everybody and now
we're tailoring it to each individual
patient are there particular advances
say in the last few years or the last
couple of years even that you're
especially excited about and they're
showing you know promise that you
wouldn't have anticipated well Eric
there's advanced is the last several
weeks that were excited about not just
the last several years so just last week
we learned in a type of lung cancer
called squamous cell lung cancer we
learned about new genes that are
abnormal in that cancer and we're
matching those two drugs that we think
might be important and some of the labs
at Yale are specifically looking at
these particular genes that were found
to be abnormal squamous cell and saying
how can we turn those jeans off so I
think this this research is developing
incredibly fast another big area we're
excited about our immune therapies for
cancer so for years we've tried to use
the body's immune system to become more
effective in cleaning and searching for
cancer cells this year for the first
time we've shown that in lung cancer
melanoma and kidney cancer we're able to
use monocle antibodies to turn on the
immune system something
we couldn't imagine three years ago let
alone ten years ago I was going to ask
you about the squamous lung cancer of
paper did you know that was coming and
we knew part of it was coming a lot of
it was reported some of the big cancer
meetings we all go to yeah and we you
know on the web we hear this we hear
these results somewhat early but that
paper was the first publication of the
data until the publication comes out you
never really know exactly what you're
dealing with yeah interesting I'm going
to take a couple of questions that have
come in to us from the general public
this one has come from Twitter and
social media it's from at Kara and she
says she asks I've been hearing a lot
about epigenetics as a new frontier in
cancer research can you explain and do
you agree that it's got some real
potential well Kara clearly knows what
she's talking about and clearly is on
top of what's happe in cancer research
so I explained that genes are at the
heart genetic change there at the heart
of what makes something cancerous well
epigenetics is really at the heart of
the genetic changes is what we're
finding so what epigenetics refers to
its it's the changes in the structure of
genes that influences how genes make
proteins so epigenetic changes have to
do with how genes are regulated within
cells okay so it's sort of a way of
thinking about is these are the elements
within a cell that can turn a gene on or
turn a gene off so you might have a
mutation but what might be more
important is that way the epigenetics
inside that epigenetic changes within
that cell can turn that gene on or turn
that gene off and that can be the
difference between whether the gene is
silent or whether the gene is active so
epigenetic changes we're appreciating
are incredibly important in cancer now
what's interesting is we have a number
of exciting drug targets that are now
being developed to go after epigenetic
changes I think that's one of the most
exciting things in cancer over the next
three to four years so it's really
primarily a research area at this point
well research very now but there are
some drugs on the market that are
actually effective in cutaneous t-cell
lymphomas for example that target the
epigenome as we call it so it's it's
it's not just research it's actually
helping patients good good I'm going to
take another question also
submitted to us by Twitter this one is
from at pre-med girl in New York City
and she asks what's the number one thing
you recommend to women with a genetic
history of breast cancer in order to
prevent it so I think Eric that's a
great question from pre-med girl I'd say
one of the things I find most
interesting there is that we talked
about how cancer is caused by genetic
changes within the cancer well we also
know that each of us brings a certain
genetic environment to our cells that we
get from our mother and our father and
so somebody who's got a history of
breast cancer in their family may be
predisposed to getting breast cancer
themselves now again 20 years ago we
didn't really know what genes were
important in breast cancer risk today we
have much more information about that
and so women who have a history of
breast cancer in their family I would
strongly recommend should talk to a
certified genetic counselor a licensed
genetic counselor to talk about whether
testing for those genes for them makes
sense because you can find out whether
or not your family risk is is actually
realized by having specific genes that
are abnormal so that's a very important
tool that's available to women now that
wasn't available ten years ago well
let's say you get that testing and you
learn that yes you're very much at risk
what can you what can you do with that
information too well that's a great
question there's lots of different
options that women can look at some
women can choose to may choose to
determine when to have their children
maybe they have their children little
bit earlier so that if they decide to
have prophylactic surgery such as
mastectomies they might have their
children their late 20s and then choose
to have prophylactic mastectomies other
women can choose to take certain
medications that can reduce the
incidence of developing breast cancer
other women might choose just to have
very close monitoring and do MRIs very
carefully to look for small changes and
try to pick the cancers up early it
becomes a woman's individual choice
again only after seeing a licensed
genetic counselor and talking to a
breast surgeon and breast cancer expert
who can help advise on these different
choices and
is tailored is another example of
personalized medicine it is tailored to
which gene is abnormal and what is the
woman's choice where how old is she what
is she what are her preferences and what
does she want to do but there are the
goodness as there are ways of reducing
that risk are we in a better position to
use those kinds of tests for with
respect to breast cancer than for other
kinds of cancers we're much better with
breast cancer than other cat types of
cancer we're getting better at
colorectal cancer so colon cancer is a
good example where we now know about
about certain genes that are seeing more
often in colon cancer i would say that
colon and breast are probably the two
most important gene predisposing gene
syndromes that we know about and where
genetic counseling has made the most
difference in cancer but every year
we're learning about new areas and new
genes that predispose to developing
cancers and there are a number of rare
genetic syndromes but in terms of common
cancers I'd say it's colon cancer and
breast cancer let me ask you a little
bit about your own specialty you're an
expert in lung cancer how did you what
is that drew you to lung cancer in
particular as a special so it's the
willie sutton law okay meaning it's
where it is the leading cause of cancer
death in the world you know it's what's
getting getting people on a broad
spectrum globally in terms of death from
cancer so I was attracted to the fact
that nobody was studying a lung cancer
it was an underappreciated disease there
was a strong feeling when i started in
lung cancer in the 90s that well the
patients smoked it's their fault why
should we do research in this area well
we know several things one it's not the
patient's fault if they smoked they
lived in a society where tobacco is
promoted incredibly heavily second there
are plenty of people who never smoked
who got lung cancer and still need to
have research done to help their cancer
there's more never smokers who died of
lung cancer then there are never smokers
who died of testis cancer Hodgkin's
disease thyroid cancer combined so it's
it's a it's a common relatively common
phenomena and that's one of the things
that drew me to it and the fact that
there was so little work being done in
lung cancer I find I found that to be
quite disturbing and I was drawn to that
and how is it going with respect to lung
cancer as opposed to others so lung
cancer during the course of my
career I think couple things have
happened first we know for people with a
smoking history who are over 55 they
should strongly consider getting cat
scan screening CT scan screening and we
can pick up nodules early and we can
save lives so that's something we didn't
know about 20 years ago only learned
about that two years ago second we've
learned about number of genes in lung
cancer and a number of new drugs that
specifically work well in those patients
who carry those genetic abnormalities
and that would be the egfr gene the alka
gene and the ross gene again exciting
things that were we looking forward to
this is sort of more of a public health
question than a medical question but
have anti-smoking campaigns publicity
campaigns seem to have affected uh you
know the incidence of lung cancer at all
they have that it's been terrific so
what we've seen is we've seen that the
age-adjusted mortality for lung cancer
among men has fallen which is terrific
because men actually stop smoking a
little bit earlier than women have we're
now starting to see among women a
flattening of the curve suggesting that
women are stopping smoking and and they
actually the number of teen smokers the
United States is finally beginning to
decline so our anti-smoking efforts have
been very successful doesn't mean we
don't need to continue them we do need
to continue them we still have a very
high smoking rate it's approximately
twenty-four twenty-five percent the
United States but efforts to reduce
smoking have definitely helped reduce
the instant lung cancer however you go
to some countries like Indonesia in
Indonesia seventy percent of men smoke
cigarettes so there are parts of the
world where tobacco is still commonly
used compared to United States in Europe
the smoking rates are dramatically
higher than they are in the u.s. in many
countries let's take another question
from a member of the public this one
comes from Gabriel Ellsworth he emailed
it to us he describes himself as a Yale
alumnus working in Kenya at 10 wek
hospital and let me quote from his
message to us quote our long-term goal
is to develop a multidisciplinary
approach in rural Kenya we would need a
full-time oncologist and a dedicated
Cancer Center which might be a long way
off we are thinking big but if you have
any advice on incremental steps to to
make
treatment more multidisciplinary in the
developing world let us know your
thoughts great question the National
Cancer Institute the United States has
made it a priority to encourage cancer
centers in the United States to begin to
partner with developing nations who are
trying to improve their cancer outcomes
so there are many universities around
the world that have efforts to try to
improve this there are partner countries
in sub-saharan Africa where there may be
one radiation machine in the entire
country and so the idea of bringing
multidisciplinary care is of high
priority to parts of Africa I think
Africa is a great example where there
are people dying of curable cancers that
aren't getting treated not getting
recognized in a timely fashion when you
look at some of the terrific in roads
that have been made in HIV in Africa
obviously not cured yet problem not
solved yet but huge improvements in
several of the countries where effort
has been put into this and
multidisciplinary focus and attention
when brought to bear in your experience
as a clinician have you perceived any
major misconceptions by and among cancer
patients and families about cancer
diseases and about their treatment I
think in terms of misconceptions I think
the the thing that probably probably
hear most commonly is you know it's
cancer contagious okay can you get
cancer from somebody else and the answer
to that is definitely no it's not
contagious viruses that may predispose
you to cancer are contagious viruses
like hepatitis human papilloma virus HIV
those are contagious but actual cancer
itself is not contagious so you don't
get cancer by hugging your grandma or or
or or hugging a patient who's got cancer
but you can't effectively get it from
your forebears right well you guys get a
genetic an get a predisposition to
cancer from your mom and dad okay so
your mom and dad can give you a
predisposition hearing cancer you know
it's something we've known for years
diseases run in families families that
have heart disease ten avila heart
disease families a lot of diabetes and
level out diabetes family to a lot of
cancer tend to have a lot of cancer
that's because of what's in our genes
are there are there any major
non-scientific challenges that you see
that facing cancer research today pull
or social obstacles so I think the
biggest thing I would say from a
political standpoint is the funding for
cancer research so right now the NIH the
total budget of the NIH is 30.1 National
Institutes of National Institute of
Health total budget nations's of Health
is 30 point 1 billion dollars that has
been declining for the past three years
one of the frustrating things is if
you're a Democrat or if you're
Republican in the past there was
bipartisan support for increasing
funding of cancer research and medical
research and what we've seen since 2003
which is now almost nine years of
relative flat funding during that time
at exactly the time when we have all
these tools and genetics to look into
diseases and to help patients I think
one of the frustrating things of the of
the gridlock in Washington and again
Democrats and Republicans are equal
opportunity blame in this situation we
need to refocus attention on cancer
research and health research in general
that's one of the things that makes this
country great it's one of the things
that we have a huge advantage globally
over other countries on and if we don't
continue to invest in research and
invest in science will miss an
extraordinary opportunity so what can
executive such as yourself at cancer
facilities do to sort of lobby for we do
that we have all of our professional
societies are actively advocating dr.
Roy herps who's the chief of oncology at
Yale Roy was on Capitol Hill yesterday
talking to senators and representatives
to advocate for more cancer funding his
Yale class of eighty-four and a huge
supporter of cancer research but also
the public needs to tell the
representatives that they care about
cancer funding hmmm it in your view what
serious cancer problems really dessert
deserve more attention than they're
getting that is either are there are
there problems that are sort of being
overlooked for one reason or another so
I think it's a great question about
about which cancers can we do a better
job on I think that there are there are
there's a question of access to care so
one of the things we know in the United
States is that if you look at people
from socioeconomically disadvantaged
backgrounds we know that access to care
is not as good we know that colonoscopy
screening rates for example are lower in
lower socioeconomic
groups of patients we want to improve
that we want to make sure that
mammograms are obtained we will make
sure that that that good preventative
cancer screenings happen better in this
country we can do a better job of doing
that in a state like Connecticut we
actually have a very high rate of
colonoscopy screening in our state and
as a result we have a lower rate of
death from colorectal cancer I'd love to
see that happen throughout the country
what do you attribute that to I actually
a great question is is it is it part of
it cultural part of it that it's
something that everyone does and if you
know that your neighbor is going to get
a colonoscopy maybe you're more likely
to get the colonoscopy too interesting
you must be asked this all the time
because it's sort of the question I
think most people who have had cancer or
half cancer or know someone who has
which is a huge percentage of the
population ask is do you believe that
cancer can be cured in the way that you
know we eradicated other diseases so
Eric one of the real goals of the Yale
Cancer Center is to increase the cure
rate of cancer without a doubt that's
why we wake up in the morning that's why
we come to work is we're working to
improve the cure rate of cancer I
believe that we will over the next 10
years begin to see improvements in the
curate doesn't mean everybody is going
to be cured it doesn't mean that we're
going to cure everyone with cancer but
we're going to begin to take that number
right now it's fifty percent of all
patients with cancer are cured we want
to keep taking that and it's not
including skin cancers we want to take
that number and increase it by a couple
of percentage points and I think that
we're going to see that number begin to
go up so yes I do believe we can
increase the cure rate of cancer maybe I
should have asked this first when we
talk about a cure for cancer how we do
how do we define cure as I would like to
tell patients i define a cure is that
you'll end up dying of old age while
you're flying to a beach in Florida to
celebrate your 95th birthday okay so
that's what I define as cure I think
somebody who lives a life without
symptoms of cancer or any evidence of
cancer causing them any difficulties
that to me is an example of cure now
what weapon demonologist call cure they
call five-year survival if you go five
years without the cancer coming back for
most cancers that's equal to cure not
for every cancer
but for most cancers smile cancer
hospital yale-new haven opened three
years ago now we open three years fully
fully occupied two years ago what's it
been like to start a cancer hospital
from scratch spent a terrific
opportunity smiled cancer hospital has
over 170 beds dedicated for cancer
patients plus 12 teams of
multidisciplinary specialists it's been
terrific to be able to bring this to the
southern connecticut area and really to
the nation our patients come from all
over the country now to come to smile of
cancer hospital and our goal now now
that the hospital is open and
established is really to focus on taking
some of the incredible science that's
happening at Yale and translate that
into new therapies for patients and
we're working really hard across the
university to bring the science of Yale
which has always been terrific to impact
on the care of patients with cancer so
it's really at the challenge that I
think all of us are incredibly engaged
in right now one more question from the
public this from a Peter lamothe in New
Haven Connecticut it's kind of on a
lighter note he wants he says that he
knows that you are a huge new england
patriots fan and wants to know what are
the odds that tom brady leads the team
to a fourth Super Bowl win this year so
I'm at Peter noses I'm feeling very
optimistic about Tom Brady doing very
well this year he had a fantastic
opening game against the Titans I expect
good things this weekend against the
Cardinals and I'd say the odds are about
75% that he brings home the fourth title
this year thanks so much for joining us
this has been really enjoyable it thanks
to all of you for watching at Yale live
please tune in again next month thanks
so much great